shannon is I get really emotional about
you it's been 21 years since kevin smith
directed shannen doherty in mall rats
but as i learned during our interview on
tuesday alongside his daughter Harley
Quinn their close bond is stronger than
ever what does she mean to you
everything the actress is reuniting with
Smith for the Mallrats TV series all
while continuing her fight against
breast cancer she praised her longtime
pal in an interview with ET earlier this
month he sent me this long email but the
beginning of it was you look so effing
metal with your haircut and it just made
me feel so good I was like oh yeah you
know like I'm a badass
when Shannon got sick like you know
naturally I was like hanging in there
stubble
when she shaved her head that's when
things got serious when she shaved her
head I sent her an email going like you
rock it's it get better soon because
we're heading toward Mallrats and she
wrote back very quickly I'm not too sick
to work don't worry get moving forward
are you kind of in awe of her strength
yeah yeah what a great way to put it yes
I mean all of anybody strengths when
they have to face the unknown or you
appreciate the genius of somebody who's
facing them face of all with absolute
grace and good humor and you're like
you're my hero